[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les petites fées qui suivent les
vedettes au petit
trou c'est qu'elles ne savent plus lire
dans les conttes de
Pérou on est sorti sans
carosses de leur livres de leur
songes pour venir en chair en os leur
raconter des mensonges
elle nous regarde
comme au viterines des
magasins elle nous
regarde comme des poupées comme des
pentins
elle nous
regarde comme un jouet qu'elles n'ont
pas eu comme un compte d'enfants
qu'elles n'ont jamais
eu les petites fées qui
suivent veê au petit trou
ell s'en vantent à la
dérive au gré des courants
radios qui sont les faits
carabos de ces apprentis
sorcières en poussant ces pauvres gosses
au fond de nos sourissières
[Musique]
elle n
regarde hypnotisé comme des chats
ell nous
regardent et leurs yeux ont de l'estomac
elles nous
regardent et sont prêt à tout pour un
rien un rien d'amour même s'il est sans
lendemain
elle nous
regarde et leur regard
d'adolescent qui nous
regardent nous fait rajunir le 100ent an
elle nous
regarde avec des yeux qui sont si grands
qu'ell nous oblige parfois à tomber
dedans et c'est peut-être bien pour ça
qu'elle nous
regardee
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]